[Music]
I'm a lawyer in legal service of
commission and responsible for the
research policy currently I'm working at
the DG environment of the European
Commission and I am a case handler
I'm a lawyer linguist in the Council on
the legal service in a Directorate known
as the quality of legislation my daily
work I assess the legislation of the
Member States where I check the
compliance of the national legislation
with the EU rules and if it's not the
case then the Commission asks the Member
States to change the legislation or
their practices lawyers here we revise
all the documents that are passed to the
commissioners for for the adoption this
is a legal revision this is revision on
the substance of the documents secondly
we represent Commission in the European
Court I have to be in regular contact
with our experts because the legislation
is is also very technical and I'm also
in contact with with different
environmental NGOs with citizens from
the Member States with representatives
from the from the industry and also
national authorities law a linguist
often confused with translators we're
not translators we're responsible as the
name of our Directorate implies for the
quality of legislation so we try and
ensure that any legislation that is
adopted by the EU is legally coherent
factually correct but also
linguistically coherent or language
versions are equally authentic so we
have to ensure that they all say exactly
the same thing
I studied law and being half English and
half Italian I studied English law and
Italian law I have a legal background so
I studied European law in Latvia I have
a bachelor's degree in science politics
and in law and master's degree in law I
first started as a trainee in the
European Commission in the in the legal
service and then I was sent to work for
the Commission as a national expert from
the from the National Authority where I
worked at the time I started my career
as a lawyer linguist in court in
Luxembourg and then opportunity arise I
was invited to work for the Commission
and I took this chance and in half a
year I started working in here in
Brussels in Commission Lingle service
you're constantly involved with the most
up-to-date legislation even before it
comes out on the news you've been
involved in to a certain extent the
negotiations for it and yes an example
was just recently working on the
accession treaty for Croatia and my
colleague that was responsible for it
then went to the the signing ceremony
metal the heads of state so there's
something quite prestigious about it I'm
working currently on the
intergovernmental treaty and so that's
yet another interesting aspect I feel in
my job that I give voice to environment
by making sure the Member States
properly apply their legislation and
their practices and if we identified
that there are some breaches then that
they're properly tackled and constant on
basis I have to find legal solutions to
a tricky situations for example
conclusion of international agreements
when the European Union concludes an
agreement with some third country first
what will we include in substance in
such an agreement to know the best serve
the you interests or some practical
considerations who will sign the
agreements
we'll be Commissioner will it be
director-general and how to be sign
shall be signed only on the last page or
does it need to be signed also on the
every page of the agreement most of the
EU institutions use English as their
working languages but then here in lingo
sirs I would say this would be
unthinkable to live also without knowing
French it happens sometimes when you get
some documents in French and then you go
to a meeting you have to express
yourself in English and then the
particularity of legal service is also
such that although we have the
Commission has three official working
languages German French and English
the European Court has only one just
French so often you have to analyze
documents which are available only in
French in the daily work I use Latvian
in English that covers a lot of Member
States because you can work with English
with most of them and the I use also
French with with my colleagues a lawyer
linguist has to speak three languages
very well to be able to get in that's
already precondition and naturally
there's always the opportunity to learn
new languages here the languages I use
essentially are English because I'm in
the English team that's the language
they use essentially in negotiations or
otherwise French the legal service is
still very much imbued with the French
culture so we do use French very often
as well
the Commission training catalog is very
big it's very diverse so basically you
can choose all sorts of training speed
the language courses or trainings for
personal development since I joined the
Commission I have followed language
classes to improve my French and I have
also followed some legal courses for
example to be acquainted with the the
new procedures of co-decision under the
Lisbon Treaty and I have also followed
some some personal development courses
like improving communication skills our
department assists us very much it
organizes a lot of training for
newcomers but also for more experienced
colleagues and I've been involved in
preparing some of those trainings and so
it's a great experience not only to
receive training but to also give
training so there's a lot of
opportunities here
I love it I wouldn't be able to adapt to
anything less than that absolutely great
perhaps I'm assisted by by my ground but
absolutely you know being in touch with
different cultures different
nationalities learning about different
traditions is is a very enriching
experience
you